so Kane the Conqueror is just one of the
most ridiculous characters in the
history of Marvel Comics check this out
so this guy of course is a time traveler
as most of you guys know and this guy
has access to technology of the future
including force fields that have been
able to withstand a nuclear bomb at
point-blank range the power of Thor's
hammer in even the Silver Surfer who at
that point in time was able to tank
Thanos this guy possesses weapons from
every point in time that he can access
at a moment's notice including an
anti-matter bomb he's also said to be
the greatest military mind in history
and his willpower strong enough that he
was able to resist reality warping which
is just absolutely nuts now if that's
not enough this guy not only conquered
Earth but was able to conquer multiple
universes to the point that in the
future he has an Empire that includes
millions of Worlds across the entirety
of the Milky Way galaxy and even
throughout the entirety of the
Multiverse this guy rules whole
universes it's nuts make sure you guys
follow for more